not backing down I want to thank the
Justice Department u.s. President Donald
Trump is praising his Attorney General
William bar after bars Justice
Department took the unusual step of
recommending a reduced sentence for
Trump Ally and close friend Roger stone
government prosecutors had requested
stone serve almost a decade in jail
after being found guilty last November
of lying to Congress during its broader
investigation into whether Trump's
presidential campaign had colluded with
Russia
you have murderers and drug addicts
it'll get nine years nine years for
doing something that nobody even can
define what he did
Trump weighed in on Twitter calling the
potential sentence horrible and very
unfair and a miscarriage of justice
that's when the Justice Department
changed its recommendation to less jail
time prompting for Justice Department
prosecutors to quit the case in protest
now there are questions about whether
Trump may pardon stone Democrats are
calling for an independent investigation
into the stone case they allege the
president who was last week acquitted in
the Senate for abuse of power is acting
with impunity they point to Trump's
firing of White House officials who
testified against him during the
impeachment inquiry as further evidence
of the abuse of presidential power left
to his own devices president Trump would
turn America into a Banana Republic
where the dictator can do whatever he
wants and the Justice Department is the
president's personal law firm as outrage
builds an online petition with tens of
thousands of names is also calling for
the Justice Department's internal
watchdog to review whether protocols
were followed in the stone case go Trump
20 but such criticism is unlikely to
hurt Trump among his supporters
that's because Donald Trump promised on
the campaign trail to drain the swap
essentially pushed back in the so-called
Washington establishment that includes
judges and
prosecutors that the President believes
are out to get him and his conservative
allies
Kimberly Hellcat al Jazeera the White
House